So now let me explain why Donald Trump is
panicking, why he has replaced his campaign
manager with only three and a half months
to go before the.
Five new election polls were released yesterday,
and Joe Biden is ahead by as little as three
points in the right leaning Rasmussen poll.
And by as much as 15 points nationally in
the latest Quinnipiac University poll.
In that same Quinnipiac poll, Donald Trump's
approval has collapsed to 36 percent.
No president has had a 36 percent approval
this close to their reelection Election Day
potential reelection.
Election Day for a very, very long time.
I think this is actually worse than George
H.W. Bush in 92.
But I'd have to go back and look.
So let's look at the new polling we got yesterday.
Just a ton of new polls, five general election
polls.
NBC News Wall Street Journal says Biden is
up by 11.
CNBC says Biden is up 10.
Rasmussen, as I mentioned, that's the right
wing pollster.
The best one for Trump has Biden up only three.
Quinnipiac is the most insane one, which says
Biden is winning by 15.
And then The Economist's YouGov poll released
yesterday says Biden is up by nine.
You also have some interesting state polls.
One from this morning in Arizona says Biden
is up five in Arizona.
A North Carolina poll from yesterday says
Biden is up.
One Florida poll says Biden up seven, which
if Biden wins Florida by seven, you're looking
at a historic defeat for Donald Trump.
Big if, big, big, big if.
In Pennsylvania, Biden is up eight.
And in Michigan, Wisconsin and a different
Arizona poll.
Joe Biden is up by six.
And then if you look at Texas, we saw one
poll earlier this week that had Biden up five
in Texas.
The latest poll out of Texas has Trump up
two.
But understand that I don't really think Texas
is a place Biden is going to win.
But Trump won Texas by nine in 2016.
If Trump only wins Texas by two, that is a
major signal about trouble for Donald Trump
nationally.
So let's pick one of these and look a little
more closely at the Quinnipiac poll.
Not only does it have Joe Biden up fifteen,
it has Trump approval at 36 percent, with
60 percent disapproving.
And the internals on specific issues are important
to look at.
So let's put up on the screen and I'll tell
you what we're looking at here.
This is the Quinnipiac poll.
Key issues, Trump versus Biden on handling
a crisis.
Biden leads 57 38 by 19 points on handling
health care.
Biden leads 58 to 35.
That's 23 points on Corona virus response.
Biden leads 59 to 35 on addressing racial
inequality.
Just brutal.
Biden ahead by 32 points.
And this is maybe the most interesting one
to me on handling the economy.
Biden is now ahead of Trump 50 to 45.
That's the most important factor to me, because
we often have this situation where Republicans
are just more trusted on the economy.
I discussed with you last week how it's not
really borne out by the facts.
Stock market does better under Democratic
presidents.
Unemployment is lower under Democratic presidents
on average.
Recessions are more likely under Republican
presidents.
Inflation is lower under Democratic presidents,
et cetera, et cetera.
But the stereotype is that Republicans are
good for the economy and for business, even
though it's actually not true.
The fact that Joe Biden now leads Trump by
five on the economy is massive because that
was essentially Trump's last stand.
So now what?
We've got it right.
We can all just kind of hang for the next
four months.
No, no, no, no.
Everyone must vote.
Do not become complacent even for a second.
We don't have it.
Trump knows he's up against the wall.
Trump knows that it takes eight to 10 weeks
to flatten the curve and that that's getting
us dangerously close to Election Day and that
the cases are still going up, not down.
So he knows he needs dirty tricks, okay.
He knows he needs deceptive online campaigns,
voter suppression, trying to hide corona virus
data or data or both, really.
So do not become complacent even for a moment.
And we'll have more coverage of this and this
latest polling on The David Pakman Show Instagram
page.
That's David Pakman show on Instagram.
Follow us there.
We'll have much more
for
you
right after this short break.